[Music]
but why some say the moon
why choose this as our goal
and they may well ask why climb the
highest mountain
five 35 years ago
fly the atlantic
we choose to go to the moon and do the
other thing
not because they are easy
but because they are hard
[Music]
[Music]
uh
lady here
we should be out there snacking on bad
guys
i am a predator
i need to be free
you have got to get control of your
aggression
we will get hauled off into area 51.
you live in my body you live by my walls
i'm sorry i don't know what came over me
please let me fix it so i can push it
again
you are a loser
eddie brock i want to give you my story
people love serial killers
jesus why me
that's mine
it's yours and what's yours
is mine
i have tasted blood before and that is
not it
all i ever wanted in this world
is carnage
i'm not increasing here
really
oh yeah
eddie
you feel like home to me
like family
oh wow you could just say i'm happy for
you that was going to be us hey i'm
happy for you
no
god i'm so sorry i'm sorry just doing
some serious couples counseling
thomas
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
hi
have we met
one kill makes you larger and
one pill makes you small
and the ones that
mother gives you
[Music]
time to
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here i know it's why you're still
fighting
and why you will never give up
you don't know me
no
logics
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
james
fate
draws us back together
now your enemy's my enemy
how did that happen
well you live long enough
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
we used to be able to get into a room
with the enemy
now they're just floating in the ether
she still loves you did you know that
what is it
is she one of them i don't know her at
all
when her secret finds its way out
it'll be the death of you
james want
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better
place i just want to be a little
tidier
i met your new double oh
she's a disarming young woman
you've ever flown one of these things
before
nope
come on bond where the hell are you
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
when you're ready you're late
can i just have one nice evening please
before the world explodes
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
right folks spiderman is in fact peter
parker listen i did not kill mysterio
the drones did the drones that are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
spiderman
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please be safe to have
the universe together i think we're
beyond you calling me sir okay
stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget the
peter parker spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj is going to forget about
everything we've ever been through stop
tampering with the spell oh my god ned
he's my best friend oh my aunt may
should believe stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
[Music]
so
from your secret friend
underneath
[Music]
let's play a game just me and you
any of this mean anything to you
[Music]
you're becoming quite a celebrity
[Music]
why is he writing to you
if you
are justice
please do not lie
what is the price for your blind
eye
[Music]
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance
oh
this guy's crazy
[Music]
you're part of this too
oh my part of it
you'll see
[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you
may very well mean the difference
between life
and death
your reputation precedes you
have to admit i wasn't expecting an
invitation back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting two versus what he's gotta be
kidding
[Music]
smoke in the air
[Music]
[Music]
i'm looking for someone who can help me
gain an audience with the czar perhaps
you can be of assistance
i only make decisions when my stomach is
full or my balls are empty
well thank god dinner is being served
[Music]
small things
can grow into big problems
[Music]
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
while governments wait for orders
our people take action
welcome to the club
you're going to need a suit
very clever
time to dance
[Music]
stop [ __ ] about
[Applause]
[ __ ] this gentleman's [ __ ] i'm gonna
love calling you
[Music]
i wish we'll see
[Music]
my planet arrakis is so beautiful when
the sun is low
rolling over the sands you can see spice
in the air
the outsiders ravage our lands in front
of our eyes
their cruelty to my people is all i've
known
what's to become of our
[Music]
world a boy
duncan can i trust you something yes
always you know that
i've been having dreams
about a girl on a raccoon
i don't know what it means
dreams make good stories
but everything important happens when
we're awake
yeah put on some muscle i didn't no
[Applause]
we are house atreides there is no call
we do not answer
there is no faith that we betrayed
smile gurney i am smiling
the emperor asks us to bring peace to
arrakis house atreides accepts
[Music]
i know you
you need to face your fears
come with me
you need to be ready
you've never met harkins before they're
not human they're brutal
the duke's son sees too much
this is why you
kill them all
god in heaven
[Music]
get everything with guns off the ground
go
this is an extermination
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
dad
what if i'm not the future of house of
treaties
a great man doesn't seek to lead
he's called to it
but if your answer is no
you'll still be the only thing i ever
needed you to be
my son
[Applause]
if anything happens
will you protect paul with my life
only together can we stand a chance
it's time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
five years ago thanos erased half of the
population of the universe
but the people of this planet brought
everyone back with a snap of a finger
the sudden return of the population
provided the necessary energy
for the emergence to begin
how long do we have
seven days
we're eternals
[Music]
we came here 7 000 years ago
to protect humans from the deviants
why didn't you guys help fight thanos or
any war all the other terrible things
throughout history
[Music]
we were instructed not to interfere in
any human conflicts and their stevens
are involved
by who
[Music]
we need to find the others
i haven't seen some of them for
centuries
hi
hello
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
you know what's never saved the planet
you're sarcasm
we have loved these people since the day
we arrived
when you love something
[Applause]
you protect it
[Applause]
you can't protect
[Music]
any of them
[Music]
i bet you've built a perfect safe house
what's this even made of vibranium
fall collection
ikea
[Music]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
[Music]
you're a gift
you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm
running out of time
this can be my last chance
[Music]
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i want to see you get hurt more than you
already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
[Music]
strength
the ability to use echolocation
is an overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go
to fix something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbiel
got tired of doing the whole good guy
thing huh what's up doc
you're a great mom
i don't know i'm fine with trevor
but with phoebe
she really keeps me on the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish you'd get into some trouble
there's still time
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke and our
grandfather left us this creepy old
farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing
well i wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here
somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason
are you troubled by strange noises in
the middle of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my
god you guys hear that
something's coming
all city
it's like the walking dead
go
we're closed
what do you want richard i'll be honest
with you
i want to do a good deed
[Music]
i want to do a lot more
the best things in life are free i try
to set an example for my nephew
anthony got kicked out of school i went
to all that trouble and for what i've
always been accused you gotta be good
i want to do whatever i can to help the
family
money don't get everything it's true
what it don't get i can't use i want
money
i wonder what they talk about in there i
didn't catch the name [ __ ]
put them on the table
i think i just got this jacket
[Music]
you know i try so hard
better do something about dickie
matasani
[Music]
i know you can get anything look at
dickie most of santi he steps up takes
care of his family takes care of all the
business
if anybody tells anybody about this
how you doing on your merry badges
[Music]
i want to do all kinds of good things
it's the one thing
[Music]
pain comes from always wanting things
but what do i know
i'm a murderer
the best things in life are free
got myself a son hi christopher hello
[Music]
like a scam or something
some babies when they come into the
world know all kinds of things from the
other side
i've been chasing their boss forever
this might go south
of a day isn't it partner
[Music]
[Applause]
up here
go go go
[Music]
you better go [ __ ] don't you touch my
baby
come on big boy come on big boy
you all need to leave
please mister
who are you i'm a cop these two just
shot my partner down the road
run
i need you to get to safety these people
will kill you this is my farm i don't
belong here
where are these guys they're drug
dealers scumbags you're my prisoner
until my boss gets here i'm finishing
this alone
this is certainly a development
you came here to kill or did any of you
not get the memo on that
because evidently this cop did
i expect you and i are so different
nothing like you i got shot today and
i'm tied up
and you still hit like a [ __ ]
you need my help that's the house that i
shared with my wife
that is all i've got left all right
let's go save them
i got you back
we killed
or be killed
run i gotta finish this
runner arrest wrong place wrong time i'm
gonna be the guy that's gonna kill you
i'm not going anywhere
this is my farm
[Music]
you